i just don't know about q anon
you do know i don't know no i don't know
you know if you go out and you want to
buy groceries you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his own doral golf club
gotta take care of the floors you know
the floors of the forest it's very
important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job that
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting in
for the secretary of state that
incredible night
with the maps and the republicans are
red
and that map was so red from chin
tendulkar to colleen
trump tweeting the new york times they
are a true enemy of the people i think
we have enough of an interview here hope
okay that's enough let's go this russian
bounty story we have multiple sources
saying
that trump knew all along i was there
for a tiny little short period of time
it was much more for an inspection there
was no problem during the day
and said quote crazy joe biden he
doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying
all the way they'll go out and they'll
vote and they're going to have to go and
check
their vote by going to the poll and
voting that way people are flushing
toilets 10 times
15 times as opposed to once the state
department
is emphasizing to world leaders that
they should stay
at donald trump's hotels and they say
the noise causes cancer you tell me that
one okay
trump ordered robert mueller the special
prosecutor
be fired the factory policy is wear a
mask at all times
and trump puts on goggles but no mask
and we're building a wall
in colorado we're building a beautiful
wall
trump floated the idea of swapping
puerto rico for greenland the ram that i
descended after my west point
commencement speech was very long and
steep
had no handrail and most importantly was
very slippery
our army manned the air it ran
the ramparts it took over the airports
it did everything it had to do
wherever trump goes he tries to make
himself seem dominant over whoever he's
shaking hands with trump's strong
looking situation room photo
was a staged photograph likely taken
hours
after the event lock them up you should
lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary i
too have a nuclear button
but it is a much bigger and more
powerful one than his
the narcissist and chief donald trump
wanted his
signature printed on all of the checks
[Music]
he's not reading a presidential daily
briefing
that has been dumbed down to one page
mostly pictures graphs and maps get that
son of a [ __ ] off the field
right now out he's fired
he's fired so in florida
i encourage all to request a ballot and
vote by mail
the win direction shifted and it sort of
split his hair sort of back to front
trump was
laughed at by the entire room of world
leaders at the united nations one of the
wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of
water and then they did dumps they call
them dumps
big massive dumps levar ball is
unaccepting of what i did for his son i
should have left them
in jail these aren't people
these are animals the same vaccine could
not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona
no cummings district is a disgusting rat
and rodent infested mess
[Music]
compared to other presidents trump has
golfed more
than any modern president cnn should be
ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude
terrible person trump showed up and
started throwing
paper towels to people like he was
shooting free throws
in basketball donald trump's decision to
do the corona caravan drive
around walter reed well it's not the
hardest test no but it
has a picture and it says and it's an
element no no you see
that's all misrepresentation that's what
the white house had put together a
statement
praising mccain and his life and his
heroism trump said no no statement i'll
post a tweet
instead this is the guy who stared
directly
at a solar eclipse i wanted to always
play it down
i still like playing it down trump
shared a video
of a supporter of his yelling white
power
toilet paper donald trump revealed
highly classified intelligence
information
to none other than sergey kislyak the
russian ambassador
you don't know until you test it but i
think i i really believe i'd run in
there even if i didn't have a weapon
trump has blamed canada for burning down
the white house in 1812.
donald trump has become the third
president in the history of the united
states to be
impeached
i guess we'll have to compare iq tests
and i can tell you who is going to win
you can test too much you do know that
who says that
oh just read the manuals read the books
manuals read the books
read the books books trump referred to
seemingly haiti african mostly non-white
countries
as [ __ ] countries trump also
tweeting
i won this election by a lot president
putin
he just said it's not russia i will say
this i don't see any reason why it would
be
he invites a college sports team to the
white house after a big win
and he serves them fast food option
number one
with bernie sanders far left on the
manifesto we do it
man that gives you socialized medicine
look hey are you still not gonna let us
know
this was the largest audience to ever
witness an inauguration
period alternative facts there are
pictures now
which appear to show boxes and boxes
of sudafed and upper he's going to
eliminate
overtime for hundreds of thousands of
postal workers
which could delay mail services and of
course prevent the
delivery of the ballot i am proud to
shut down the government
for border security because the people
of this country
don't want criminals and people that
have lots of problems
in fact i'll get that little piece of
dandruff for
a little bit we have to make him perfect
he is perfect
i think that would qualify as not smart
but genius
and a very stable genius at that
but it gives me it gives me power
trump paid a total of 750
in federal income taxes the year that he
won the presidency
god bless the palestinians and god bless
the united states thank you very much he
shoves the president of montenegro
philip voyanovic out of the way and then
we fell in love
okay now really he wrote me beautiful
letters
they're trying to take you out with
[ __ ] okay
president donald trump has been
impeached again
making him the only president in history
to be impeached
two times we appreciate it very much tim
apple
trump called troops who died losers
and suckers i hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges or the oranges of
the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation trump
uh had protesters tear gassed
and dispersed with horses for donald
trump to walk
to saint john's church and be
photographed
holding up a bible millions and millions
of people voted for us tonight
and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchise that group
of people
i got it i got it why don't we nuke them
trump said we drop a bomb
inside the eye of the hurricane and
disrupt it so what are we going gonna do
here folks i only need 11 000 votes
fellas i need 11 000 votes give me a
break
twitter has banned donald trump
permanently from its platform michael
cohen alleges the hush money payments
for which he was convicted
for which he pled guilty were
specifically directed specifically
requested of him by donald trump himself
donald trump fired fbi director james
comey not
make any more threats to the united
states
they will be met with fire and fury
days before the july phone call between
donald trump and the ukrainian president
donald trump ordered
military aid be withheld from ukraine
with a black circle potentially a
sharpie
used to draw in a section of the florida
panhandle
and pieces of alabama
stand back and stand by the mueller
report
there is an incredible amount of
evidence of obstruction
extraordinarily damaging to donald trump
and to the people around him
so interesting to see quote progressive
democrat congresswoman who originally
came from countries
whose governments are a complete and
total catastrophe the worst
why don't they go back and help fix the
totally broken and crime infested places
from which they came president donald
trump has announced that he has tested
positive for coronavirus donald trump
removed his mask and what i guess was
supposed to be framed as some kind of
act of courage
the trump administration is also scaling
up the number of children
that are going to be held in these
internment style camps
right and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out
in a minute one minute and is there a
way we can do something like that
by injection and we're going to the
capitol
usa
[Music]
we love you you're very special what
a video what a countdown and what a
tragic chapter in the history of the
united states of america
which we hopefully are moving beyond uh
from
a uh on a permanent basis on a permanent
basis welcome everybody tonight is
the first speech to a joint session of
congress by president joe biden
it's basically a state of the union but
that's not what it's called
during the first year but needless to
say we are just 49 minutes away from the
start of this
event and we are very very much looking
forward to it
for those just joining me uh let's start
with
my assessment of what we are going to
hear tonight joe biden is going to
propose a very big package tonight
1.8 trillion dollars which will include
free community college it will include
paid family leave and many other
elements
and there's a very interesting piece in
the la times
which argues that joe biden is
essentially the opposite of reaganomics
and tomorrow i'm going to be talking
about this in more detail but
you don't have to like everything that
joe biden does
you don't have to see biden as the
progressive
a standard-bearer because he's not to
recognize
that biodynamics is really
the antithesis of reaganomics and we may
be
in a new era of american economic policy
uh errors come and go and at some point
we're going to be a new era and this may
be the start of it
reaganomics focusing on supply
side stimulus whereas joe biden is doing
the opposite joe biden
is very much going fully into demand
side stimulus let's
stimulate demand with covet relief
with other types of government spending
reaganomics believes that
if you give people help it makes them
lazy
by dynamics believes that if you give
people help
it actually frees them to be
self-determining more productive members
of society
these are completely antithetical views
reaganomics wants to limit the money
supply
and in part with higher interest rates
biodynamics believes that
actually a larger money supply is okay
and it welcomes lower
interest rates which some economists
believe are going to be you know sip
as close to permanent as we can say
about anything nothing is permanent of
course
uh and so i'm gonna expand on this
tomorrow but this is essentially um
if you ask me what is the hundred day
sort of um what no we can't really call
it a legacy
what is the theme of the first hundred
days of biden
i would call it the opposite of
reaganomics
and hopefully uh something that we will
continue to build on this is not we're
only 100 days in this is certainly not
the end
um so though that that's my thought so
far and we're going to see
many many things tonight that i think
will be interesting it will be
interesting to see
what uh the republican reaction is to
the things that joe biden is going to
propose so a great evening
and it may finish off with us taking
some phone calls which would be
really really great okay let me thank a
few people who are already supporting
the stream uh grungy dan
as well as john ouivi have subscribed
via twitch prime which is a special
thing that you can do
i also want to say a really special
thank you to trey adkins who just signed
up on my website joinpacman.com
using the secret coupon code immoral21
welcome trey great to have you here
let me run through a few super chats
that people are generously
sending in via youtube denver says i'm
here and highly palpitated youtube
wouldn't let me say the other word you
used oh titillated yeah
you suck wants to know when i will
appear on the h3 podcast
anytime they invite me anytime the
client clients want to have me
steven says a hell of a year for rudy
giuliani caught with a hand down his
pants with borat's daughter four seasons
hair dye melts farts gets covered house
raided by fbi yeah we're going to talk
about rudy momentarily
trevor asks if i think biden will demand
filibuster reform tonight i don't know
i don't know that's a good question and
super taco says the cops who entered the
house in boone
were trespassers the man defended
himself no warrant
no entry cops will probably kill him now
disgust
i don't know what you're saying exactly
super taco let me investigate that
and then i will uh get back with you
uh i have so many things today that i
don't even know where to start
let's start with a let's start with a
twitch unban request
twitch has a mechanism through which if
you are unfortunate enough to be banned
you can ask to be unbanned i will
adjudicate these requests with a gavel
that i have
a user named florida birdwatcher was
banned yesterday
they first participated in the channel
yesterday
they said people that wear masks while
alone are wimps
they are [ __ ] look at that scared
little lib
you will get your ass beat by a proud
boy soon
so much for freedom of speech from lib
nuts
david pakman you are an enemy enemy of
this great nation you need to be doxed
and permanently silenced they were
banned
their unban request is for you to ban me
on twitch it is unconstitutional this is
a public entity where people engage in a
free-flowing exchange of ideas
banned and permanent just too stupid
there it is adjudicated and done that is
a perma-ban
uh good good night good evening and good
morning my friend we just we're just not
gonna do it
it's just trash it's bottom feeding
trash
let's see thomas says will we ever see
you back on the joe rogan experience i'm
glad to appear anytime
we released a video today very critical
of joe rogan on his
recent vaccine comments and i would be
glad to discuss those with him in person
so i'm glad to reappear anytime joe
wants to have me if he does
borah rudd says i was today years old
when i learned twitch subscriptions need
to be renewed every month
got a twitch account only to give you my
bezos
bucks yes very important
in social as well as dranoa
damixty and astrolycos have just joined
in on the twitch party
putting us at seven which is just a
beautiful number
draconian drug laws in scandinavia says
how good are you at mathematics david
pakman terrible
absolutely terrible crazy nate says
david i heard about some bipartisan
talks they even passed an asian hate
crime bill 94-1
think we can get that transferred to
some big bills i am not optimistic that
there will be any republican support for
the things that joe biden will propose
tonight
i just don't see it i hope i'm wrong
john cesar says love the thumbnail thank
you
joe rader says david did you do the
drums in your new theme music i did not
i did not uh okay so we took care of
unbanned requests
what else do i have um i have a new
voicemail caller this is
a new anti-vaxx individual i've not
pre-screened these that's
let's just listen to what they have to
say
new to all of us
hey mr pacman um i'm wondering
when you're going to get around to
covering the story about
dr uh hotez out of the
center for vaccine development and the
fact that
he had a yeast based
spike protein vaccine
almost as soon as the chinese government
released the original genetic sequence
for
yeah everybody had i mean the sequencing
happened within hours of that that's
dr hotez was not the only he's not
unique in that way go on
wild-type sarsko v2 virus
i believe that dr hotes was approaching
the federal government
as well as a number of big
pharmaceutical companies
trying to get a sponsor to
subsidize and participate in
a accelerated clinical trial
for this yeast-based vaccine
which if and when it ever is approved
will cost approximately a dollar and
fifty cents per dose
okay so this times out at the maximum of
three minutes
and then they call back in with a second
voicemail right away
so just to continue moderna and pfizer
used the pandemic crisis to obtain
accelerated trial approval
which saved millions of dollars
off of the cost of getting the mrna
technology certified for emergency use
okay in the meanwhile yeast-based
vaccine
has already been used to produce of
highly successful hepatitis
b vaccine that is currently approved
what is going on here
and there are no new special exclusive
patents
for yeast-based vaccine technologies
and so it's a very cynical game that's
being played
up to this very minute where the
artificially created
man-made shortage of vaccines is being
perpetuated there's really no shortage i
mean in the sense of
we in the u.s now there's more supply
than demand and we're starting to send
them around anyway i don't know where
he's going but there's a third voicemail
to cap this
so a number of
virologists immunologists and
epidemiologists
who are asking that we do the same thing
that we're doing for
visitors from other countries who only
got one astrazeneca shot and are
finishing off their vaccine course
okay which is to allow them to get their
second dose
in the form of a pfizer or moderna vax
shot because all we're doing is
man guys it's just like just go get
vaccinated what are we doing here i i'm
off of it all right i'm sorry guys if
people wanted to keep it going we're not
gonna we'll just
you know maybe we'll do some kind of
special or something like that okay
i wanna say thank you to a new member
named coupon code
isn't working coupon code isn't working
just signed up using the coupon code
immoral21 and his new member number
eight today at joinpakman.com
if you've been thinking about signing up
on the website today is a great day to
do it because if we do get to 100
by the end of the speech we will open
phone lines wide wide open
i also want to say thank you to prague
janesh
as well as bounce the cat
link dranoa for a gift
c missile for the twitch sub captain
flash heart
aspire is number seven lola supernova
number eight liquid ice number nine
mikzawa is ten colors atk is eleven
very exciting jumping us out to 19
already
a few other super chats what the hell is
a yeast based vaccine oh yeah you can
make challah with it when you're done
you get injected and then you are immune
and then you make a
chala bread with raisins or without i'll
have it either
way it's a beautiful bread i see biden
has used the power of the office to
raise the federal government contractor
minimum wage to 15
an hour do you see that as the first
step to the minimum wage
being next i hope so do you think if
biden gets all of his most popular
policies will the dems do well in the
midterms
yes also hey nice shirt thank you
david thoughts on u of i klein center
advanced social research saying the six
riots can officially be called a coup
d'etat i have not seen what they said
i'm sorry
i'm unable to comment on that um
i will get back to super chats
very very good let me play here's a deep
fake someone just sent this to me they
said they made a deep fake of me and
tucker i've not pre-screened this let's
take a listen
oh whoops hold on a second whoa is that
me and tucker that's crazy
look at that some explanation but it's
pretty fascinating
a couple of days ago tucker carlson fox
news propaganda
ran a kind of strange out-of-place
commentary on his show
yep where he vaguely referred to his
college year
the reverse tan with like my my reverse
uh raccoon eyes are even done
beautifully her books and people like
jeff bezos looking for dirt
on tucker carlson and it was weird
because yeah it was just out of context
it seemed to have nothing to do with
what was going on on tucker's show
yeah i don't look confused enough here
yeah and it raised the question of
whether tucker carlson was trying to get
ahead of a maybe embarrassing or
problematic story
so let's start by taking a look at that
this is the clip from a couple of nights
ago just kind of out of nowhere yeah
what this was about
that's really well done that is that is
nicely done
column one time about his displeasure
with the fact that gay people exist now
to me this is less about whether tucker
carlson
was home my hands like don't match my
face it's like somehow he's edited my
my head to be too little for the size of
my hands homophobic in 1990 or 1991
as a sort of potential disqualifier for
tucker to do
whatever today first of all there's tons
of people that are homophobic
secondly i don't think being homophobic
is considered a problem for fox news
host that may even
man that is that is creepy that is
really really creepy but
nicely done i mean i appreciate i
appreciate you uh
sending that to me hold on let's close
that out uh oh
so today rudy giuliani's office and
apartment were raided
and it just like central casting clearly
was on alert today
you have to see some of these videos
here is one of
rudy's neighbors michelle herbert and
like
could you couldn't possibly cast this
uh uh oh oh no
hold on a second oh no my mouse died
my bat the batteries on my mouse died
this is a disaster
um hold on a second
you see see if my wired mouse can reach
oh it can okay all right so i'll use the
wired mouse for now
wow that was almost i should have like a
backup mouse
uh okay here is here's rudy's neighbor
it's like you know the every every one
of these characters is perfectly cast
i know i just saw people i probably saw
fbi jackets
but i just saw people you know and i saw
all of you and
and i said what is going on
what is going on here here's another one
they're probably
maybe up still up there into this
apartment i really don't know they were
bringing out a lot of stuff
so that's a statement from rudy's
neighbor michelle herbert
um and then we had here is rudy
giuliani's son
andrew giuliani and he's very upset
mind you i'm speaking as a son and a
concerned american
right anybody any american whether
you're red
or blue should be extremely disturbed
by what happened here is it whether
you're a redditor or blue
today by the continued politization
of the justice department this is
politization
that's uh that's something disgusting
this is absolutely absurd
and it's the continued politization of
the justice department that we have seen
the politician yeah here's another the
only piece of evidence
that they did not take up there today
was the only piece of incriminating
evidence
that is in there and it does not belong
to my father
it belongs to the current president's
son
yeah the real story here guys is not
that rudy's in trouble
it's hunter biden's laptop which
apparently was in rudy's apartment
here we go back to a michelle herbert
providing us with more of a
more information the funniest thing is
my ex-husband called me
and said have you seen what's going on
and i i said you said no look out your
window
so so there could not possibly
uh have cast and my understanding is
that francis ford coppola really worked
with her to get this
character down just perfect and you can
tell i mean really a
commitment to the craft there so that is
uh that's michelle herbert very very
exciting stuff
and we are we are standing by for uh
joe biden this evening so we'll we're
going to get back to that
tomorrow on the show and uh man just
what you know
it's it's every detail of the rudy story
is just nuts okay um
we are standing by for joe biden a few
other things oh well hold on i want to
say thank you to adam smith
author of the wealth of nations who has
just signed up at joinpakman.com
i want to say thank you to cody
mcallister who just signed up at
joinpackman.com and i want to say thank
you to patrick mcnamer
who all just signed up at
joinedpakman.com putting us at 22
for the evening also a big thank you
to twitch user i'm inconsolable who just
gifted
eight subs also thanks to bada boom bada
bing
uh for the twitch sub stack that cheese
that's 32 and thanks for the continued
gift bits from odwd
inc the coupon code is working
immoral 21 dies at midnight
let's see who we have here looks like
mitch mcconnell here
is this who is this who is that there is
that kamala harris i can't tell
yeah i believe it is there's kamala
harris the vice president here's mitch
mcconnell
um patrick leahy maybe with his back to
us
that might be roy blunt is this lindsay
i can't tell man it's hard to tell what
who who
all these people are um but things are
things are getting going
a few other super chats pepe xanadu
wants me to look at their last message
my uncle contracted bell's palsy as a
side effect of the vaccine this is his
reward for doing the right thing
unbelievable
um okay i don't know anything about that
so i i would not be able to comment on
that
john says i want to go to buenos air
buenos aires argentina when covet is
over where should i go
yes you should go to buenos aires do you
know of any tips of anything interesting
there
everything is interesting there rocco
thompson is a hot dog a sandwich no it
is not
have you seen a live soccer match
argentina boca et cetera
uh yes although i don't remember the
last one i've been to
but i have here's some money for mouse
batteries i have a whole thing of double
a's
just not in this room so we'll see uh
if i can get that taken care of a little
bit later
this is my favorite joe biden moment
somebody clipped this from yesterday's
live stream i really like this take a
look
and we will do this right thank you all
and god bless you and as much as the
temptation is to stay outdoors in this
beautiful day i've got more work to do
thank you all very very much
the risk is so low outdoors why doesn't
it apply to everybody
would you have any preconditions before
meeting with vladimir putin
i uh one at a time
if the risk is so low outdoors why
doesn't this new guidance apply to
everybody
because the science indicates that this
most certain way to make sure it doesn't
spread of both people
have been vaccinated the people you're
with and you're outside
and you chose to wear a mask sir you
chose to wear a mask you chose to wear a
mask as you walked out here
what message were you sending by wearing
a mask outside alone and watching me
take it off and not put it back on till
i get inside
right wow do you have any preconditions
before meeting with vladimir putin
there we go so that is a beautiful
hammer drop moment there
for uh joseph r biden jr very very nice
um as we continue to see people
head into the house chamber there
beautiful beautiful moment with joe
biden there
big thank you to brian waltos for
signing up at joinedpakman.com also
thanks to random
sarcasm for signing up at
jointpakman.com putting us at 34.
also really really big time action
happening on twitch
caspa has just gifted a sub sarah adams
has just subscribed magnum satan has
gifted five
that's seven seven plus thirty four
seven plus four eleven carry the one
one plus three is four puts us at forty
one can anybody
check that with a ti-83 i want to make
sure we're
spot on here uh i think that was alex
padilla her replacement greeting her
david what are your thoughts on the 2021
boston mayoral race i am
not taking a position on it would kamala
be a good president if biden died
yes yes absolutely
uh okay
oh let's do this real quick i still have
free memberships available
the the current contest we haven't
wrapped up this contest because it just
hasn't
hasn't we don't have enough submissions
yet the challenge
was to do a remi a show related remix of
this infamous video
[Laughter]
okay so we have some submissions all
right let's go through the submissions
so
far still an opportunity to get in
friday is the deadline okay friday oh no
sunday sunday is the deadline get your
submissions in
to info davidpakman.com
these are these are submissions now
[Applause]
right guess what i got a fever
and the only prescription is more
cowbell
it was a perfect storm really
welcome to san francisco mr bukowski
[Music]
these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
okay so that's one submission here's
another one there is a literal
crime rate
[Applause]
[Music]
the fake news is creating violence
a big beautiful wall
[Music]
a powerful wall bye bye we're leaving
bye enjoy yourself there it is
all right next submission
[Laughter]
notice the american crew fiber hair
product not a sponsor
[Music]
oh by the way thanks to molina gorensen
also known as
molina destiny bonnell
ii for hosting with the 3 800 viewers
we're about to watch joe biden very much
appreciate that
okay anyway so you get the idea here's
another submission
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
all right i think you get it here's a
paula white version come down
let it be burned by the fire of god
right now in the name of jesus
god worship the lord worship the lord
for the lord demands a worship right now
the lord demands a worship right now a
lot going on here
your worship will rise above it for your
worship will rise above it
for your worship what the hell's going
on
i mean what the hell is going on
it's hard to pinpoint exactly where this
fiasco
started
okay uh here's another one we just got
two more
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right i think you get that one and
then here is the last one
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so pretty weird but that's uh
that's what's going on all right
looney lindsey graham entering the uh
the chamber
so that's it there's still an
opportunity to get your submissions in
and i would encourage you
to do so uh an historic
evening an historic evening and we now
have
really really strong live video starting
to come in and so okay good so now we
are we are here
let me see if i can get caught up and
thank everybody that i can
we are trying to open phone lines after
this historic
evening uh and if we
let's see what's going on daniel barry
has signed up on my website
amanda wheeler is a new member
jacob meek has signed up the memberships
are dumping in almost faster than i can
read them
sayyam rodri sumi long
has gifted two that's 44 plus
four oh god that is the that is
complicated math um
okay so so nothing really going on quite
yet um
a lot happening and uh we do tonight is
today is the last day for this coupon
code
it's not that one that's the the known
coupon code better21
weird what's going on we just lost it we
are going with the
secret coupon code immoral 21
last evening for it uh there is our
friend eric swalwell big fan of the
david pakman show uh
i believe this is is that chuck schumer
uh patrick leahy here that's kamala
harris nancy pelosi
i think this is like a clerk maxine
waters not sure who that is there's a
bernard sanders
a lindsey graham that's joni ernst
senator from iowa
lot happening here guys a lot a lot
happening on this historic evening
uh joe smith asking any huge dumps in
arizona not at this time
i want to say a big thank you to odwdin
for gifting 28 subscriptions on twitch
putting us at 76 a stunning
stunning number um and just a lot
a lot happening today difficult to even
keep up with everything that's taking
place
but we are going to have quite an
evening ahead of us joe biden will be
laying out
the next step in biodynamics
i believe this is hakeem jeffries former
guest on the david
pakman show next to amy klobuchar
a lot of a lot of political stars
gracing us with their presence in the
house chamber
um aviator says could you check my last
super chat
okay let's see aviator david i wanted
your thoughts on cryptocurrency in
regards to changes to capital gains
taxation will the change harm crypto
i don't know what the change is uh i i
have not uh stayed up on that
if you tell me what the change is i'd be
able to comment
there's willard mitt romney
senator from utah
i announced today on the world famous
award-winning bonus show
i am looking at going to alaska very
soon i have no
whoa joe manchin going maskless
he is refusing that is a mass refusal
from joe manchin
yeah i've never been to alaska i'm
looking at going in the next couple of
months
probably will fly into anchorage since
that
is the most convenient place really to
fly to um
and so i'm interested in doing a number
of different things and if people have
suggestions if you've been to alaska
i'm not looking to camp you know i mean
it's you know my
my idea of camping is the hotel's
minibar
has few selections you know that's my
idea of camping but i
i am looking to do a number of different
things that's a joke by the way
um but yeah please uh please
email info davidpakman.com with alaska
suggestions some people are saying rudy
has the gop health care plan in his
apartment that's why it was rated yeah
we're finally going to figure out
what is in trump's health care plan it's
going to be great
thanks to noog wrangler for gifting
two subs also ranch fiend has subscribed
putting us at
79. also a lot happening at
joinedpakman.com
i want to say thanks to jerry casiba
for the new membership thanks to george
florence or you oh ed markey and
elizabeth warren the massachusetts
delegation your florence has signed up
david hurlbert is a new member matt
babcock has signed up putting us
at 83. you know the challenge was a
hundred by the end of the speech
we may hit 100 by the start of the
speech the way things are going
john wants to know whether kamala will
have a difficult time winning
oh god look at kennedy this guy just
that man disgusts me
do you think kamala will have a
difficult time winning the 24 primary if
she fumbles immigration reform
i'm not even going to think about a 24
primary until we know whether joe
biden's running
so i'm taking it step by step as i like
to do thanks to
rodrigo nunes for signing up at
joinpakman.com new member number 84
today
bernie talking to maxine waters and
another gentleman
uh i assume he's a gentleman anyway
yeah i mean so far we've seen some
maskless uh
unmasked individuals
you know i i think we are done with the
outdoor masks but
hear the policy is wear a mask and you
should do it you should do it
have you heard from the fetterman camp
no
uh producer pat has reached out once or
twice to the fetterman camp i don't
believe we have heard back
jennifer says i may be able to help i
know his wife please do we would love
to have john fetterman on the program
would absolutely love to do it
very interesting guy big thank you to
rocco saldana as well as chris brown
chris brown um new members 85 and 86
today
also thanks to havland uh
derek haveland and derek new members 87
and 88
there is disgusting vile ted cruz
talking to delusional ignorant lauren
beaubert
no word as to as whether as to whether
lauren beaubert is
strapped tonight will either mccarthy or
mcconnell tear the speech papers
i don't think they get a copy of the
speech
alaska has good strip clubs just kidding
search the abc go fishing in seward i
was stationed there for three years and
deployed to iraq for 15 months
interesting interesting how you be so
cute genetics i think it's just genetics
zachary egan has just signed up at
joinpakman.com thanks zachary zachary's
new member number 89 today
e sizzle has also gifted a sub on twitch
number 90.
missed my last super chat an interesting
question all right
sorry soliman considering a
parliamentarian has said democrats can
do one more reconciliation which bill
would be best
infrastructure versus families you know
i'm kind of leaning towards
the one the package he's unveiling
tonight because i think it would most
immediately benefit individuals whereas
infrastructure is
is longer term but uh
i don't know i could be convinced
otherwise
i could be convinced otherwise david do
you think nina turner would change how
progressives operate in the house if
nina is elected no one person is going
to change everything but she would
certainly move things
in that direction for sure
i believe here we have roy blunt i think
this is kevin mccarthy a horrible person
who else can we see was that joni ernst
down here i think it is
what does the joint session mean joint
session means that it is the house and
senate together in the house of
representatives
looks like we are going to hear
something from nancy
the chair appoints as members of the
committee
on the part of the house to escort the
president
of the united states into the chamber
wow
the gentleman from maryland mr hoyer the
gentleman from south carolina
mr clyburn the gentlewoman from
massachusetts
ms clark the gentleman from new york mr
jeffries the gentleman from california
mr aguilar
the gentlewoman from delaware ms blunt
rochester
the gentleman from california mr
mccarthy
the gentlewoman from wyoming miss cheney
the gentleman from oklahoma mr cole
the gentleman from town all right so
this is perfunctory stuff we will see
when joe biden is ready to enter
um
lauren beaubert represents my
congressional district says benjamin
she's our queen with a capital q
yes i understand what you're saying uh
we are
matching the audience that c-span has
for this event
on youtube alone if you include our
twitch
and facebook audiences we are exceeding
the c-span audience at this point in
time which is
unbelievable an unbelievable evening
i've been to alaska five times i'll send
you recommendations yeah
and listen i'm not looking to like i
don't want to go on
you know a a touristy crab experience
with
a hundred other people i'm not looking
to ed to do any kind of like tourists
being corralled i prefer to rent a car
and to do the stuff myself in small
groups or on an individual basis you
know
i reject all of this incredibly touristy
stuff
thank you pleasure uh mmm
has subscribed via twitch so has noah
phillip hickey
the littlest sunbean ky dizzle
gifted 10 that's 13 brad the psychic is
14 anselm is 15
15 plus 90 wow
we are 105 and the phone lines are going
to be
wide open after the speech and they're
they are pouring in
julian sigmund has just signed up on my
website thank you julian
jackson godsey has just signed up on my
website
kevin noyola new website member
g-bone eagleton has just signed up
ryan o'toole is a new member muhammad
kingson has signed up and
william poon is a new member putting us
at 112 because it's such a special
evening
the phones will open but let's go for
306
the number of uh electoral votes with
which
joseph r biden jr won
i missed a 28 sub bomb no i don't think
i did i got that
i got it from odw we announced that sub
bomb that was huge
uh and that actually put odw within
striking distance of top three all-time
gifters
uh starting to get there inconsolable
still running away for
with it um we are not opening phone
lines before there's only nine minutes
until the speech
do you think republicans will heckle joe
biden like you lie
we'll see yeah i think it's a
possibility i think it's a possibility
on behalf of all canadians i apologize
for the repulsive calgary-born
ted cruz he represents the opposite of
everything we value and believe in i
believe you
i believe you here's the massachusetts
senatorial delegation
ed markey and elizabeth warren having a
chat
um very exciting do you think bobert and
greene will be able to behave like
adults tonight
i don't know if green it looks like it's
a reduced capacity so i don't i mean we
saw bobert i don't know if
marjorie taylor green is going to
actually be here
that's unclear to me i know some of them
are going to have to be in the gallery
as well
so we're going to keep an eye on that
but uh certainly i'm i'm curious whether
anybody will shout out at any time
thanks to freddie bob for the twitch
prime sub also thanks to east sizzle for
the gift
and marzu fazu has been subscribed now
for 14 months very much appreciate that
um also i really do want to thank hinda
ader
hinda ader just signed up with the
coupon code
immoral21 it is a secret unpublished
coupon code
what it does for you just be careful
also thanks to chance baker for signing
up on my website number 117
we will be taking phone calls at the
conclusion of joe biden's speech
only 200 in attendance got it got it
that's good to know
let's get a little bit of a sense of the
atmosphere in the room
oh looks like they've killed the audio
okay
types uh someone like roy blunt okay
no problem we're gonna keep an eye on
the uh
we're gonna keep an eye on what's going
on here a lot certainly taking place
um yeah who i'm sorry who's doing the
response i forgot who's doing the
republican rebuttal
can somebody remind me i just
i just lost my train of thought i don't
i have no memory of who it is
is it tim scott oh okay i thought tim
tim scott has done it before i think
right yeah
very good clark is my rep in
massachusetts do you see her as future
speaker don't know enough about her
i hope biden comes in with his aviators
on and doing finger guns yeah that would
be something
that would be something
still unsure is this a q a with the
president and members of congress
no this is biden is doing a speech it's
like a state of the union they just
don't call it that
during the first year that a new
president is in office but it's
basically a state of the union address
trump was wrong i actually won the
election says cody from canada
that's unlikely would i go back on the
jesse lee peterson show if invited
yeah maybe
madam speaker the dean of the diplomatic
poor
right so people are starting to file in
and we're sort of down to the last few
minutes here before joe biden
enters the chamber looking forward to
a full room next year
different situation this year certainly
thanks to will barker for signing up on
my website at joinpacman.com really
appreciate that will
joe biden presumably just moments away
as we continue to see folks slowly enter
most wearing masks we saw
joe manchin not wearing a mask we saw
a republican senator john kennedy not
wearing a mask
do people think there will be republican
heckling that's a that's an interesting
question
i'm cur i think if there you know
politics has been coarsened
to such a degree that it really wouldn't
shock me
but at the same time i'm not saying i
expect it
it will be a covet barrett be in the
crowd i get weird vibes from her yeah
she has a look she has the look of a
like someone who's in a cult
and in fact i think she is i don't know
if all supreme court justices will be
here today
thanks to logan butcher logan butcher is
a new member
number 119 today really appreciate that
also thanks for the thousand bits from
odwd
inc so great to see so many people today
madam speaker the chief justice of the
supreme court
so maybe it's just john roberts who will
be here maybe that's
the sort of coveted uh
modification they've done where it will
only be john roberts i don't know
but there he is going with the black
mask a uh
gucci mask made from italian leather of
course
it looks like it's just him that's kind
of awkward
thanks to fighting jack for the twitch
prime sub number 120 today
also a big thank you to james barris
as well as osvaldo kai
new members on my website website is
doing some work tonight working
perfectly
we are just five minutes from joe
biden's entrance
please enable captioning on the c-span
feed
glad to do that
joe manchin is giving the rebuttal yeah
well said
he might as well right um
standing by for joe biden typically we
will be able to see
um joe biden kind of arriving i don't
know if we will today
soak dem gem says hey david destiny said
you are unable to give more moderate
takes due to a strong leftist audience
is this true
no uh i just oh there's a doctor jill
biden
i give my takes on the show regardless
of
what anybody wants i just give my
opinion that's it
it's always my real opinion
[Applause]
big thank you to jen dyal
who has just signed up on my website
those last minute memberships dumping in
also thanks to dooston as well as aliz
via twitch we should be
normally you see biden arrive and like
the whole motorcade
but it doesn't seem like we have
coverage of that today that's okay
a speech to a joint session has the same
legal weight as any other speech so why
have it during a pandemic with the pomp
and circumstance
everybody in the room is vaccinated
essentially they don't have that many
people
in the room and everybody's wearing
masks it seems totally reasonable to me
i have no problem with it whatsoever
to christopher krapinski as well as
stephen patterson
and also gersogar saycon
hope i didn't butcher that too too badly
for signing up on my website also thanks
to toilet duck
oh boy things getting real toilet duck
multi-beast
and darkest fett have signed up via
twitch putting us at 131
mortadella is a rich man's baloney says
daniel
yeah i don't eat pork so i don't know
much about it
i really don't can't wait for all the
unity talk after not a single republican
voted for the covet bill
yeah pathetic
here we go madam speaker
representatives of the president's
cabinet
cabinet members will now be entering
i am not good at recognizing the cabinet
i think that's lloyd austin
okay how do i feel about biden's
standpoint on police reform what do you
think he might get into tonight agree or
disagree curious
yeah i have so many clips on police
reform i don't even really know exactly
what biden's
package is on police reform so i
wouldn't be able to say for sure but
i've outlined my 10-point police reform
plan before
von tuck says destiny is a willfully
obtuse drama queen
that's not the type of drama i'm going
to get involved in
just not uh not interested in that
there is dr jill biden fox news will of
course remind you that she is not a
medical doctor
but a doctor nonetheless anders
jacobson has just signed up on my
website and is new member 132
this is senator ben cardin here this is
sherrod
brown um not recognizing anybody else
there
a historic evening and historic evening
i would argue both
and joe biden presumably uh making his
way
to the house chamber there is um
douglas emhoff the second gentleman
blowing kisses to people what a nice guy
i i'm a fan of emhoff i'm not gonna lie
follow him on instagram by the way
if you want to see the insanity
i recently got into over the weekend
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
there is some wacky wacky [ __ ] going on
on my
instagram excuse me i'm sorry
um wild wild times though
thanks to jason nichols for signing up
at joinpackman.com new member number 133
tonight
also thanks to sven hout for signing up
via twitch
a lot of people i once read a statistic
that 90 percent of amazon
prime members do not gift their twitch
prime sub to anyone that is just
tens of thousands of dollars in bezos
bucks sitting in jeff
bezos's pocket instead of independent
producers there is steny hoyer
steny hoyer fist bumping a variety of
different people
god i hope that's steny hoyer otherwise
this is humiliating
james clyburn coming up next
um is that congresswoman clark there is
hakeem jeffries who's been a guest on
this program great guy
[Applause]
i think this is kevin mccarthy here
quite a weaponized individual
and joe biden coming very very soon
big thank you to jeff beale as well as
michael
sumbasakis for signing up on my website
at joinpackman.com
also thank you to toilet duck for the
gift ubidibi dranoa
sorium hapster gilligan a lot of people
signing up there
via twitch we are now gaveling in
is that patrick leahy again he's just
everywhere these days
there's bernard sanders
newsmax is going to be covering me
swearing on a live stream i don't know
if i can live it down
there's amy klobuchar followed by senate
majority leader charles schumer from the
state of new york of course
amy klobuchar does have stories from
minnesota to tell but not not tonight
tonight is not her night
thanks to billy big wheels as well as
friendly neighborhood incel
for signing up via twitch insells are
welcome here everybody's welcome quite
frankly just don't troll
that's the only rule moderators will
drop the banhammer
[Music]
joe biden will be entering soon will you
be expanding the show to tv if you get
big enough
yeah tv's done the show's already on tv
nobody even knows because
online is where it's at right now
nancy pelosi and vice president kamala
harris standing by for joe biden
i'm very interested in this speech
tonight thanks to zero
kiwi or zero kiwi for gifting five
subs on twitch very much appreciate it
would be unbelievable to get back into
the four digits on twitch
the vacation i took really crushed us
isn't that sad
truly tragic an historic evening
do i think eugene goodman will get the
congressional medal of honor
congressional medal of is that what it's
called i don't know will
i'm not sure about that
uh but it's certainly conceivable many
people
wanting to honor the work of eugene
goodman
thanks to unconfuzzled as well as jimbo
given the thumbs up
is this the new sergeant at arms here
madam speaker
the president of the united states
there is joe biden fist bumps today
joe biden will be unveiling a 1.8
trillion dollar package tonight
lobbying for it there is senator pat
leahy from vermont
senator chuck schumer wearing a sharp
blue suit there wow love that color
john roberts the chief justice of the
supreme court joe biden greeting him
here is bernie sanders
an abbreviated entrance given the lack
of people in the crowd of course
[Music]
thanks for having members of congress
i have the high privilege and distinct
honor to present to you the president
of the united states
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you thank you joe biden
attempting to cut short the applause
which can go on for some time
mitch and chuckle understand it's good
to be almost home
down the hall anyway thank you all madam
speaker
madam vice president
no president has ever said those words
from this podium no president has ever
said those words
and it's about time wow
not everybody thrilled with that already
[Applause]
first lady i'm her husband
second gentleman oh man
chief justice
members of the united states congress
and the cabinet distinguished guests
my fellow americans while the
setting tonight is familiar this
gathering
is just a little bit different a
reminder of the extraordinary times
we're in
throughout our history presidents have
come to this chamber to speak to
congress
to the nation and of the world to
declare war
to celebrate peace to announce new plans
and possibilities
tonight i come to talk about crisis
and opportunity about rebuilding the
nation
revitalizing our democracy and winning
the future
for america i stand here tonight
one day shy of the hundredth day of my
administration
100 days since i took the oath of office
and lifted my hand
off our family bible and inherited a
nation
we all did that was in crisis the worst
pandemic in a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
now after just 100 days
i can report to the nation america
is on the move again
turning parallel into possibility
crisis to opportunity setbacks and the
strength
we all know life can knock us down
but in america we never ever ever
stay down americans always get up
today that's what we're doing america is
rising anew
choosing hope over fear truth over lies
and light over darkness
after 100 days of rescue and renewal
america is ready for a takeoff in my
view
we're working again dreaming again
discovering again and leading the world
again
we have shown each other and the world
that there's no
quit in america none
100 days ago america's house was on fire
we had to act and thanks the
extraordinary leadership of
speaker pelosi majority leader schumer
and the overwhelming support of the
american people democrats independents
and republicans
we did act together we passed the
american rescue plan
one of the most consequential rescue
packages in american history
we're already seeing the results
nancy pelosi leading the hype we're
already seeing the results
after i promised we'd get 100 million
covet 19 vaccine shots
into people's arms in a hundred days we
will have provided over 220 million
coveted shots
in those hundred days that is a number
thanks to all the help of all of you
who wouldn't clap for vaccines look at
some of these clowns would your help
boo vaccines marshalling every federal
resource
we've gotten vaccines nearly 40 000
pharmacies
and over 700 community health centers
where the poorest of the poor can be
reached
we're setting up community vaccination
sites
developing mobile units to get to hard
to reach
communities today
ninety percent of americans now live
within five miles of a vaccination site
everyone over the age of 16
everyone is now eligible to get
vaccinated
right now right away go get
vaccinated america go and get the
vaccination
they're available
right eligible now ted cruz clapping for
vaccines
when i was sworn in on january 20th less
than one percent of the seniors in
america were fully vaccinated against
coven 19.
100 days later 70 percent
of seniors in america over 65 are
protected
fully protected senior deaths from cover
19 are down
80 percent since january down 80 percent
because of all of you
and more than half of all the adults in
america have gotten at least one shot
a mass vaccination center in glendale
arizona
i asked the nurse
i said what's it like she looked at me
and she said
it's like every shot is giving a dose of
hope
as a phrase a dose of hope a dose of
hope for an educator in florida
was a child suffering from an autoimmune
disease
wrote to me said she's worried that she
was worried about bringing the virus
home
she said she then got vaccinated at a
large site
in her car she said she sat in her car
when she got vaccinated and just cried
cried out of joy and cried out of relief
parents seeing the smiles on the kids
faces for those who were able to go back
to school
because the teachers and school bus
drivers and cafeteria workers have been
vaccinated
grandparents hugging their children and
grandchildren instead of pressing hands
against a window
to say goodbye it means everything
those things mean everything you know
they're still
you all know it you know it better than
any group of americans
there's still more work to do to beat
this virus
we can't let our guard down but tonight
i can say because of you
the american people
our progress these past hundred days
against one of the worst pandemics in
history
has been one of the greatest logistical
achievements
logistical achievements this country's
ever seen
what else have we done in those first
hundred days
we kept our commitment democrats and
republicans
of sending 1400 rescue checks to 85
percent of american households
were already sent more than once 160
million checks out the door
it's making a difference you all know
when you go home
for many people it's making all the
difference in the world
a single mom in texas who wrote me she
said
she couldn't work but she said the
relief check
put food on the table and saved her and
her son
from eviction from their apartment
a grandmother in virginia who told me
she immediately took her granddaughter
to the eye doctor
what does he mean democrats and
republicans like not a single republican
voted for that bill
one of the defining images at least from
my perspective in this crisis has been
cars lined up cars lined up for
miles and not
not people just barely ever start those
cars nice cars
lined up for miles waiting for a box of
food to be put
in their trunk i don't know about you
but i didn't ever think i'd see that in
america
and all of this is through no fault of
their own
no fault of their own these people are
in this position
that's why the rescue plan is delivering
food and nutrition assistance to
millions of americans facing hunger
and hunger is down sharp oh he meant
citizens okay got it
we're also providing rental assistance
you all thank you but the american
people i want to make sure they
understand
keeping people from being evicted from
their homes
providing loans to small businesses to
reopen
and keep their employees on the job
during these hundred days an additional
800 000
americans enrolled in the affordable
care act when i established a special
sign-up period to do that
800 000 in that period
we're making one of the largest one-time
ever investments ever
in improving health care for veterans
critical investments to address the
opioid crisis
and maybe most importantly thanks to the
american rescue plan we're on track
to cut child poverty in america in half
this year
nope republicans don't like that
and in the process
all this was all going on the economy
created
more than one million three hundred
thousand new jobs in a hundred days
more jobs
more jobs in the first hundred days than
any
president on record the international
monetary fund
nancy is really leading the hype tonight
monetary fund is now estimating our
economy will grow at a rate of more than
six percent this year
that'll be the fastest pace of economic
growth in this country in nearly four
decades
america's moving moving forward
but we can't stop now we're in
competition with china and other
countries
to win the 21st century we're at a great
inflection point
in history we have to do more than just
build back better
to build back we have to build back
better we have to compete
more strenuously than we have throughout
our history
we think about it public investment and
infrastructure
has literally transformed america our
attitudes
as well as our opportunities the
transcontinental railroad
the interstate highways united two
oceans and brought a totally new age of
progress
to the united states of america
universal public schools and college aid
open wide the doors of opportunity
scientific breakthroughs took us to the
moon
now we're on mars discovering vaccines
gave us the internet
and so much more
these are investments we made together
as one country
and investments that only the government
was in a position to make
time and again they propel us into the
future
that's why i propose the american jobs
plan
a once-in-a-generation investment in
america itself
this is the largest jobs plan since
world war ii
creates jobs to upgrade our
transportation infrastructure
jobs modernizing our roads bridges
highways
jobs building ports and airports rail
carters transit lines
it's clean water and today
up to 10 million homes in america and
more than 400
000 schools and child care centers
have pipes with lead in them including
drinking water
a clear and present danger to our
children's health
american jobs plan creates jobs
replacing 100
of the nation's lead pipes and service
lines so every american
can drink clean water
still dealing with lead pipes can you
imagine
and the process will create thousands
and thousands of good paying jobs
it creates jobs connecting every
american with high-speed internet
including 35 of the rural america that
still
doesn't have it it's going to help our
kids
and our businesses succeed in the 21st
century economy
and i'm asking the vice president to
lead this effort if she would
because i know get done
she's going to do it guys she said yes
building a modern power grid
our grids are vulnerable to storms hacks
catastrophic failures with tight tragic
results
as we saw in texas and elsewhere during
the winter storms
the american jobs plan will create jobs
that lay thousands of miles of
transmission lines needed to build
a resilient and fully clean grid
we can do that
look
american jobs plan will help millions of
people get back to their jobs
and back to their careers
two million women have dropped out of
the workforce during this pandemic
2 million and too often because they
couldn't get the care they needed
to care for their child or care for an
elderly parent who needs help
joe manchin's bored in reading 800 000
families like reading a book on the
medicare waiting list right now
bizarre to get home care for their aging
parent
or loved one with disability if you
think it's not important
check out in your own district democrat
or republican
democrat or republican voters
their great concern almost as much as
the children is taking care
of an elderly loved one who can't be
left alone
medicaid contemplated it but this plan
is going to help those families
and create jobs for our caregivers with
better wages and better benefits
continuing to cycle growth for too long
we fail to use the most
important word when it comes to meeting
the climate crisis
jobs jobs
jobs
willard likes jobs for me
when i think climate change i think jobs
american jobs plan will put engineers
and construction workers to work
building more energy efficient buildings
and homes
electrical workers ibew members
installing 500 000 charging stations
along our highways
so we can own i'm looking for those
chargers
i want to be able to plug in easily
farmers
farmers planting cover crops so they can
reduce the carbon dioxide in the air and
get paid for doing it
look is he going to give us the new meat
limits though how many steaks can i have
there is simply no reason why the blades
for wind turbines can't be built in
pittsburgh instead of beijing
no reason none
the cost will be different the cost
would be different
so folks
there's no reason why american american
workers
can't lead the world in the production
of electric vehicles and batteries
there is no reason we have this capacity
one of the brightest best trained people
in the world
the american jobs plan is going to
create millions of good paying jobs jobs
americans can raise a family on
as my dad would then say with a little
breathing room
and all the investments in the american
job plan will be guided by one principle
by american buy
america
and i might note parenthetically
that does not that does not violate any
trade agreement
it's been the law since the 30s buy
american
american tax dollars are going to be
used to buy
american products made in america
to create american jobs that's the way
it's supposed to be and it will be in
this administration
and i made it clear to all my cabinet
people
extraneously limited it will be american
products
now i know some of you at home are
wondering
whether these jobs are for you
so many of you so many of the folks i
grew up with
feel left behind forgotten in an economy
that's so
rapidly changing it's frightening
i want to speak directly to you because
you think about it
that's what people are most worried
about can i fit in
independent experts estimate the
american jobs plan will add
millions of jobs and trillions of
dollars to economic growth in the years
to come
it is a it is a eight-year program
these are good-paying jobs that can't be
outsourced
nearly 90 percent of the infrastructure
jobs created in an american jobs plan
do not require a college degree
75 percent don't require an associate's
degree
the american jobs plan is a blue collar
blueprint
to build america that's what it is
republicans don't even like that they
don't like anything
recognized as something i've always said
in this chamber and the other
good guys and women on wall street but
wall street didn't build this country
the middle class built the country and
unions built the middle class
republicans definitely don't like unions
to pass protect the right to organize
act the pro act and send it to my desk
so we can support
the right to unionize
bernie loves it while you're thinking
about sending things to my
desk let's
raise the minimum wage to 15
wow no one
no one working 40 hours a week
no one working 40 hours a week should
live below the poverty line
we need to ensure greater equity and
opportunity for women and while we're
doing this let's get the paycheck
fairness act to my desk as well
equal pay wow much too long where is the
bill
you wonder whether it's too long look
behind me
and finally american jobs plan will be
the biggest increase in non-defense
research and development on record
we'll see more technological change
and some of you know more about this
than i do
we'll see more technological change in
the next 10 years than we saw in the
last 50.
that's how rapidly
artificial intelligence and so much more
is changing
and we're falling behind the competition
with the rest of the world
decades ago we used to invest two
percent of our gross domestic product
in america two percent of our gross
domestic product
in research and development today
mr secretary that's less than one
percent
china and other countries are closing in
fast
we have to develop and dominate the
products and technologies of the future
advanced batteries biotechnology
computer chips clean energy
the secretary of defense can tell you
and those you on
work in national security issues know
the
defense department has an agency called
darpa
the defense advanced research project
agency
the people who set up before i came here
and that's been a long time ago
to develop breakthroughs that enhance
our national security
that's their only job and it's a
semi-separate agency it's under the
defense department
it's led to everything from the
discovery the internet
to gps and so much more it's enhanced
our security
was the internet discovered or invented
the national institute of health
the nih i believe should create
a similar advanced research projects
agency
for health
and that would here's what it would do
it would have a singular purpose to
develop breakthroughs
to prevent detect and treat diseases
like
alzheimer's diabetes and cancer
i'll still never forget when we passed
a cancer proposal in the last year as
vice president
almost nine million dollars going to nih
and i've excused the point of personal
privilege and i forget you standing
mitch and saying name and after my
deceased son
it meant a lot but so many of us
had to see sons daughters and relatives
who died of cancer
i can think of no more worthy investment
i know of nothing that is more
bipartisan
so let's end cancer as we know it it's
within our power
it's within our power to do it
finally something republicans will clap
for
investments in jobs and infrastructure
like the ones we're talking about
have often had bipartisan support in the
past
vice president harris and i met
regularly in the oval office with
democrats and republicans and discussed
the jobs plan
and i applaud a group of republican
senators who just put forward their own
proposal
so let's get to work i wanted to lay out
before the congress my plan
before we got into the deep discussions
i'd like to meet with those who have
ideas that are different
they think are better i welcome those
ideas
but the rest of the world is not waiting
for us
i just want to be clear from my
perspective doing nothing
is not an option
there's a trump is sending endless paid
super chats to me on
on youtube it's weird i think they spent
50 bucks so far
we can't be so busy competing with one
another
that we forget the competition that we
have with the rest of the world to win
the 21st century
secretary blinking can tell you i spent
a lot of time with president xi
traveled over 17 000 miles with him
spent the time over 24 hours in private
discussions with him
when he called to congratulate him we
had a two-hour discussion
he's deadly earnest
about becoming the most significant
consequential nation in the world
he and others
autocrats think that democracy can't
compete in the 21st century
with autocracies because it takes too
long to get consensus
to win that competition for the future
in my view
we also need to make a once in a
generation investment
in our families and our children
that's why i've introduced the american
families plan tonight
which addresses four of the biggest
challenges facing american families and
then turn america
this is the package first is access to
good education
when this nation made 12 years of public
education universal
in the last century it made us the best
educated
best prepared nation in the world it's i
believe the overwhelming reason that
propelled us
to where we got in the 21st in the 20th
century
but the world's caught up or catching up
they're not waiting i would say
parenthetically
if we were sitting down we set a
bipartisan committee together and said
okay we're going to decide what we do in
terms of government providing for free
education
i wonder whether we'd think as we did in
the 20th century
that 12 years is enough in the 21st
century
i doubt it
12 years is no longer enough today
to compete with the rest of the world in
the 21st century
that's why my american family's plan
guarantees four additional years of
public education for every person in
america
starting as early as we can
the great universities in this country
have conducted studies of the
last 10 years it shows that adding two
years of universal high quality
preschool
for every three-year-old and
four-year-old no matter what background
they come from
puts them in the position to be able to
compete
all the way through 12 years and
increases exponentially their
prospect of graduating going on beyond
graduation
the research chose when a young child
goes to school not daycare
they're far more likely to graduate from
high school
and go to college or something after
high school
when you add two years of free community
college on top of that
you begin to change the dynamic
we can do that
and we'll increase pell grants and
invest in historical black college and
universities
tribal colleges minority serving
institutions
the reason is they don't have the
endowments
but their students are just as capable
of learning about cyber security
just as capable of learning about
metallurgy met
all the things that are going on that
provide those jobs of the future
alchemy jill is a community college
professor
who teaches today as first lady she's
long
said
she's long
joe any country that out educates us
is going to out-compete us
she'll be deeply involved in leading
this effort thank you jill
second thing we need american families
plan will provide access
to quality affordable child care
we guarantee
liz likes it
he's pleased and i'm proposing them
legislation to guarantee
that low middle income families will pay
no more than
seven percent of their income for high
quality care
for children up to the age of five
the most hard-pressed working families
won't have to spend a dime
third the american family's plan will
finally provide up to 12 weeks of paid
leave and medical leave family medical
wow we're one of the few industrial
countries in the world
no one should have to choose between a
job
and a paycheck or taking care of
themselves and their loved ones their
parent or spouse or child
and fourth the american family plan puts
directly into the pockets of millions of
americans
in march we expanded tax credit for
every child
in a family up to three thousand dollars
per child
if you're under six years of age i mean
excuse me under over six years of age
and three thousand six hundred dollars
for children
over six years of age i think that's
under parents two kids that's
those those controversies in the pockets
they're going to help take care of your
family
and that will help more than 65 million
children and help cut child care poverty
in half
and we can afford it
so we did that in the
in the last piece of legislation we
passed
but let's extend that child care tax
credit at least through the end of 2025.
the american rescue plan lowered health
care premiums for nine million americans
who buy their coverage under the
affordable care act
i know that's really popular this side
of the aisle
but let's make that provision permanent
so their premiums don't go back up
in addition to my family's plan i'm
going to work with congress to address
this year
other critical priorities for american
families
the affordable care act has been a
lifeline for millions of americans
protecting people with pre-existing
conditions protecting women's health
and the pandemic has demonstrated how
badly how badly it's needed
let's lower deductibles for working
families on the affordable care and
affordable care act
and let's lower prescription drug costs
yeah i know how to do this prescription
drugs was a hundred day promise which he
has failed on
we have to be aware of that lauren
beaubert doesn't like anything
we all know how outrageously expensive
drugs are in america
in fact we pay the highest prescription
drug prices
of anywhere in the world right here in
america
they shouldn't even show beau bert
nearly three times
for the same drug okay
what other countries pay we have to
change that and we can
let's do we talked about for all the
years i was down here in this in this
body
in congress let's give medicare the
power to save
hundreds of billions by negotiating
lower
drug prescription prices right but we
got to do it it's the thing
cruz wants higher and by the way
it won't just won't just tell people on
medicare
lower prescription drug costs for
everyone and the money we save which is
billions of dollars
can go to strengthen the affordable care
act and expand medicare coverage
benefits
without costing taxpayers an additional
penny
it's within our power to do it let's do
it now
good luck working with these people
though
we've talked about it long enough
democrats and republicans
let's get it done this year this is all
about a simple premise
health care should be a right not a
privilege in america
show bernie cut to bernie
so no that's not bernie
how do we pay for my jobs and family
plan right
i made it clear we can do it without
increasing the deficits
let's start with what i will not do okay
i will not impose any tax increase on
people making less
than four hundred thousand dollars it's
but it's time for corporate america uh
oh and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share
willard's in trouble calling his
financial advisor saying sell before the
cap gains rate goes i have arguments
with my
friends in the democratic party i think
you should be able to become a
billionaire and a millionaire
but pay your fair share a recent study
shows
that 55 of the nation's biggest
corporations
paid zero federal tax last year
zero those 55 corporations
made in excess of 40 billion dollars in
profit
nancy has options in 12 of them taxes
through tax havens in switzerland and
bermuda
and the cayman islands and they benefit
from tax loopholes and deductions
for offshoring jobs and shifting profits
overseas
it's not right we're going to reform
corporate taxes
so they pay their fair share and help
pay for the public investments
their businesses will benefit from as
well
mcconnell not moving not just wealth
we take the top tax bracket for the
wealthiest one percent of americans
those making over 400 000 or more
back up to where it was when george w
bush was president whoa
39 39.6 wow
that's where it was when george w was
president that's crazy
we're going to get rid of the loopholes
allow americans to make more than a
million dollars a year
and pay a lower tax rate
on their capital gains and americans who
receive a paycheck
i don't know how much money that will
generate one percent of all americans by
that action three tenths of one percent
because a lot of them will just wait to
sell rs is going to crack down on
millionaires and billionaires who cheat
on their taxes that's good
it's estimated to be billions of dollars
my think tanks are left right and center
i'm not looking to punish anybody
but i will not add a tax burden
additional tax burden to the middle
class in this country
they're already paying enough i believe
what i propose is fair
fiscally responsible and it raises
revenue to pay for the plans i propose
and will create
millions of jobs that will grow the
economy
and enhance our financial standing in
the country
when you hear someone say they don't
want to raise taxes on the wealthiest
one percent
or corporate america ask them
whose taxes you want to raise instead
who's they going to cut
look the big tax cut of 2017.
remember it was supposed to pay for
itself
yeah right and generate vast economic
growth
can you imagine instead it added
two trillion dollars to the deficit
it was a huge windfall for corporate
america
and those at the very top instead of
using the tax saving to raise wages and
invest in research and development it
poured billions of dollars into the
pockets of ceos
in fact the pay gap between ceos and
their workers
is now among the largest in history
according to one study
ceos make 320 times what the average
worker in their corporation makes
used to be in the below 100.
the pandemic has only made things worse
20 million americans lost their job in
the pandemic
working in middle class americans at the
same time
roughly 650 billionaires in america
saw their net worth increase by more
than one trillion dollars in the same
exact period
let me say it again 650 people increased
their wealth
by more than one trillion dollars during
this pandemic
and they're now worth more than four
trillion dollars
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
and it's time to grow the economy from
the bottom in the middle out
like i said the opposite of reaganomics
the opposite of reaganomics
we'll have a big story on that tomorrow
you know there's a broad consensus of
economists left right and center and
they agree
with i'm proposing will help create
millions of jobs and generate historic
economic growth that's true
these are among the highest values
investments we can make as a nation
i've often said our greatest strength
is the power of our example not just the
example of our power
my conversation with world leaders and
i've spoken over 38
40 of them now i've made it known
i've made it known that america is back
you know what they say
the comment i hear most of all from them
we know
they say we see america's back but for
how long
but for how long my fellow americans
we have to show not just that we're back
but we're back to stay
and then we aren't going to go alone
75 million trumpists have something to
say about that
allies no one nation
can deal with all the crises of our time
from terrorism to nuclear proliferation
mass migration cyber security climate
change as well
what as experiencing now pandemics
there's no wall high enough to keep any
virus out
and our own vaccine supply as it grows
to meet our needs and we're meeting them
we'll become an arsenal for vaccines for
other countries
just as america's arsenal for democracy
for the world
and the consequence influenced the world
but every american will have access
before that occur every american of
access
to be fully covered by covet 19 from the
vaccines we have
look the climate crisis is not our fight
alone it's a global fight
the united states accounts as all of you
know less than 15
of carbon emissions the rest of the
world accounts for 85 percent
that's why i kept my commitment to
rejoin the paris accord because if we do
everything
perfectly it's not going to only matter
i kept my commitment to convene a
climate summit right here in america
with all the major economies of the
world
china russia india european union
and i said i'd do in my first hundred
days i want to be very
blunt about it i had
my attempt was to make sure
that the world could see there was a
consensus
that we are at an inflection point in
history and kent's consensus is
if we act to save the planet we can
create millions of jobs
and economic growth and opportunity to
raise the standard of living almost
everyone around the world
if you've watched any of it and you were
all busy i'm sure you didn't have much
time
that's what virtually every nation said
even the ones that aren't doing their
fair share
the investments i proposed tonight also
advance the foreign policy
in my view that benefits the middle
class that means making sure every
nation
plays by the same rules in the global
economy including china
my discussions in my discussion with
president xi i told him
we welcome the competition we're not
looking for conflict
but i made absolutely clear
that we will defend america's interests
across the board
america will stand up to unfair trade
practices and undercut american workers
in american industries like subsidies
from state to state-owned operations and
enterprises
and the theft of american technology
intellectual property
i also told president xi that we'll
maintain a strong military presence in
the indo-pacific
just as we do for nato and europe not to
start a conflict but to prevent one
there are republicans convinced biden is
going to war with china
i don't see it
i just don't see it i told them what
i've said to many world leaders
that america will not back away from our
commitments
our commitment to human rights and
fundamental freedoms and to our
alliances
and i pointed out to him no responsible
american president
could remain silent when basic human
rights are being so blatantly violated
an american president president has to
represent the essence of what our
country stands for
america is an idea the most unique idea
in history
we are created all of us equal
it's who we are and we cannot walk away
from that principle
and in fact say we're dealing with the
american
idea with regard to russia
i know it concerns some of you but i
made very clear to putin
that we're not going to seek excuse me
escalation but their actions
will have consequences they turn out to
be true and they turned out to be true
so i responded directly proportionately
to russia's interference on our
elections and the cyber attacks on our
government and our business
they did both of these things
and i told them we would respond and we
have
but we can also cooperate when it's our
mutual interest
we did it when we extended the new start
treaty on nuclear arms
and we're working to do it on climate
change but
he understands we will respond
on iran and north korea nuclear programs
that present
serious threats to american security and
the security of the world
we're going to be working closely with
our allies to address
the threats posed by both of these
countries through
through diplomacy as well as stern
deterrence
and american leadership means ending the
forever war in afghanistan
we have
wait now republicans don't clap for that
they clapped for it when trump
was going to do it without hyperbole the
greatest fighting force in the history
of the world
i'm the first president of 40 years and
knows what it means to have a son
serving in a war zone today we have
service members serving in the same war
zone as their parents did
we have service members in afghanistan
who are not yet born
on 9 11. the war in afghanistan as we
remember the debates here
were never meant to be
multi-generational undertakings
of nation-building lloyd austin double
mass we went to afghanistan to get
terrorists the terrorists attacked us on
9 11.
and we said we would follow osama bin
laden to the gates of hell
to do it if you've been in the upper
conar valley you've kind of seen the
gates of hell
and we delivered justice to bin laden we
degraded the terrorist threat
of al-qaeda in afghanistan and after 20
years of value
valor and sacrifice it's time to bring
those troops home
it's over we're getting out
even as we do will maintain over the
horizon capacity to suppress
future threats to the homeland make no
mistake
in 20 years terrorists has terrorism has
metastasized
the threat has evolved way beyond
afghanistan
those of you in the intelligence
committees the foreign relations
committee defense committees
you know well we have to remain vigilant
against the threats of the united states
wherever they come from
al qaeda and isis are in yemen syria
somalia
other places in africa in the middle
east and beyond
and we won't ignore what our
intelligence agencies have determined to
be the most lethal terrorist threat to
the homeland today
white supremacy is terrorism there it is
we're not going to ignore that either
my fellow americans look nicely done to
come together
to heal the soul of this nation it was
nearly a year ago before her father's
funeral
when i spoke with gianna floyd george
floyd's young daughter
she's a little tight so i was kneeling
down to talk to her
so i could look her in the eye she
looked at me she said
my daddy changed the world
well after the conviction of george
floyd's murderer
we can see how we won't even say his
name
if we have the courage to act i like the
not saying his name
we've all seen the name of injustice on
the neck of black americans
now now's our opportunity to make some
real progress
the vast majority of men and women
wearing a uniform and a badge serve our
communities and they serve them
honorably
i know them i know they want
standing ovation for police
now republicans clap okay there's jim
jordan
they want to help meet this moment as
well
my fellow americans we have to come
together
to rebuild trust between law enforcement
and the people they serve
to root out systemic racism in our
criminal justice system
and to enact police reform in george
floyd's name
that passed the house already i know
republicans have their own ideas
and are engaged in a very productive
discussions with democrats in the senate
we need to work together to find a
consensus
but let's get it done next month by the
first anniversary of george floyd's
death
the country supports this reform and
congress should act should act
we have a giant opportunity to bend the
arc of the moral universe toward justice
real justice
and with the plans outlined tonight we
have a real chance to
root out systemic racism that plagues
america
and american lives in other ways a
chance to deliver real equity
good jobs good schools affordable
housing
clean air clean water being able to
generate wealth and pass it down
to generations because you have access
to purchase a house
real opportunities in the lives of more
americans black white latino asian
americans native americans
look i also want to thank the united
states senate
for voting 94-1 to pass the covet 19
hate crimes act to protect
asian american and pacific islanders
the eleanor holmes norton i believe
there decisively
you can see on television the
viciousness of the hate crimes
we've seen over the past year this past
year and for too long
i urge the house to do the same and send
the legislation to my desk which i will
gladly anxiously sign
i also hope congressman get to my desk
the equality act to protect lgbtq
americans
just get it done all
transgender americans watching at home
especially young people
you're so brave i want you to know your
president has your back
another thing let's authorize the
violence against women act which has
been law for 27 years
a lot of silence still people in that
room
[Applause]
it'll close the act that has to be
authorized now will close the boyfriend
loophole
to keep guns out of the hands of abusers
the court order said this is an abuser
you can't own a gun would love a mention
of d.c statehood
is to close that loophole that existed
you know it's estimated that
50 women are shot and killed
by an intimate partner every month in
america
50 a month let's pass it
and save some lives
and i need to i need not tell anyone
this but gun violence has become an
epidemic
in america the flag at the white house
was still flying at half-mast
for the eight victims of the mass
shooting in georgia
when 10 more lives were taken in a mass
union in colorado it's basically
permanent half mountain
in the week in between those two events
250 other americans were shot dead in
the streets of america
right 250 shot dead
i know how hard it is to make progress
on this issue
in the 90s we passed universal
background checks
a ban on assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines that hold a
hundred rounds
that can be fired off in seconds
delusional bobert just shaking her head
at everything shootings and gun violence
decline
check out the report over ten years
probably tried to carry a gun in there
tonight
the law expired we've seen daily blood
said since i'm not saying if the law
continued we wouldn't see bloodshed is
there anyone more vile than bober more
than two weeks ago in the rose garden
surrounded by some of the bravest people
i know the survivors and families who
lost loved ones to gun violence
i laid out several of the department of
justice
actions that are being taken to impact
in this epidemic
one of them is banning so-called ghost
guns
these are homemade guns built from a kit
that includes directions how to finish
the firearm
the parts have no serial numbers
so they show up at crime scenes and they
can't be traced
the buyers of these ghost gun kits
aren't required to pass any background
check
anyone from a criminal or terrorist
could buy this kit and within 30 minutes
have a weapon that's lethal yeah but the
second amendment you know and i'll do
everything in my power to protect the
american people for this epidemic of gun
violence but it's time for congress to
act as well
i don't want to become confrontational
but we need more senate republicans to
join the overall majority of democrat
colleagues and close the loopholes
required in background check purchases
have gone
come on you republican clowns assault
weapons in high capacity
join them and don't tell me it can't be
done
we did it before and it worked
talk to most responsible gun owners and
hunters
they'll tell you there's no possible
justification for having 100 rounds
in a weapon
what do you think deer wearing kevlar
vests
they'll tell you that they're too many
people a day
who are able to buy a gun but shouldn't
be able to buy it
these kinds of reasonable reforms have
overwhelming support from the american
people including
many gun owners the country supports
reform news
and congress should act this shouldn't
be
a red or blue issue and no
amendment to the constitution is
absolute
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
they are going to go nuts with them at
the beginning
there are certain guns weapons that
could not be owned by americans
certain people could not own those
weapons
ever we're not changing the constitution
we're being reasonable i think this is
not a democrat or republican issue i
think it's an american issue
and here's what else we can do
immigration has always been essential to
america
let's end our exhausting war over
immigration
for more than 30 years politicians have
talked about immigration reform
and we've done nothing about it it's
time to fix it
on day one of my presidency i kept my
commitment to send a comprehensive
immigration bill to the united states
congress
if you believe we need to secure the
border pass it because it has a lot of
money for high-tech border security
if you believe in a pathway to
citizenship pass it
there's over 11 million undocumented
folks the vast majority of here
overstaying visas pass it
we can actually if you actually want to
solve a problem
i've sent a bill to take a close look at
it
we have to also have to get the root
problem of why people are fleeing
particularly this
to our southern border from guatemala
honduras and el salvador
the violence the corruption the gangs
the political instability hunger
hurricanes earthquakes
natural disasters when i was president
my president when i was vice president
president asked me to focus on providing
help needed to address the root causes
of migration
and it helped keep people in their own
countries instead of being forced to
leave
the plan was working but the last
administration decided it was not worth
it i'm restoring the program and asked
vice president harris to lead our
diplomatic effort to take care of this
i have absolute confidence to get the
job
now look if you don't like my plan
let's at least pass what we all agree on
congress needs to pass legislation this
year to finally secure protection for
dreamers
right the young people just get that off
the table
[Music]
and permanent protection for
immigrants who are here on temporary
protective status
ted cruz was pretending to sleep i
missed that man-made and natural made
violence
and disaster
as well as the pathway to citizens where
farm workers had put food on our tables
look
immigrants have done so much for america
during this pandemic
and throughout our history the country
supports immigration reform
we should act let's argue over it let's
debate it
but let's act and if we truly
want us to restore the soul of america
we need to
protect the sacred right to vote
most people republicans don't want to do
that
they almost lost they did lose
more people vote in the last
presidential election than anything they
almost got blown out even more
in the middle of the worst pandemic ever
it should be celebrated instead it's
being attacked
congress should pass h.r one and then
john lewis voting rights that can
send it of course
and congress should act now
they're just against everything tonight
the image of a violent mob assaulting
this capital desecrating our democracy
remained vivid in all our minds lives
were put at risk many of your lives
lives were lost extraordinary courage
was summoned
the insurrection was an existential
crisis a test
on whether our democracy could survive
and it did
but the struggle is far from over the
question of whether our democracy
will long endure as both ancient and
urgent
as old as our republic still
vital today can our democracy deliver on
its promise
that all of us created equal in the
image of god had a chance to lead lives
of dignity
respect and possibility can our
democracy
deliver the most to the most pressing
needs of our people
can our democracy overcome the lies
anger hate and
fears that have pulled us apart
america's adversaries the autocrats of
the world
are betting we can't and i promise you
they're betting we can't
they believe we're too full of anger and
division and rage
they look at the images of the mob that
assaulted the capital as proof
that the sun is sending out american
democracy but they're wrong
you know it i know it but we have to
prove them wrong
we have to prove democracy still works
that our government still works and we
can deliver
for our people in our first hundred days
together
we've acted restore people's faith in
democracy to deliver
we're vaccinating the nation we're
creating hundreds of thousands of new
jobs
we're delivering real results to people
they can see it feel it their own lives
opening doors of opportunity
guaranteeing some more fairness and
justice that's the essence of america
that's democracy in action our
constitution opens with the words as
trade as it sounds
we the people well it's time to remember
that we the people
are the government you and i
not some force in the distant capital
not some powerful force that we have no
control over
it's us it's we the people
in another era when our democracy was
tested franklin roosevelt reminded us
in america we do our part we all
do our part that's all i'm asking
that we do our part all of us and if we
do that
we will meet the center challenge of the
age by proving that democracy is durable
and strong
autocrats will not win the future we
will america will
and the future belongs to america
as i stand here tonight before you in a
new and vital hour of life and democracy
of our nation
and i can say with absolute confidence i
have never been
more confident or optimistic about
america
not because i'm president because what's
happening with the american people
we've stared into the abyss of
insurrection and autocracy
pandemic and pain and we the people did
not
flinch at the very moment our
adversaries were certain we'd pull apart
and fail
we came together we united
with light and hope we summoned the new
strength
new resolve to position us to win the
competition of the 21st century
on our way to a union more perfect
more prosperous and more just
as one people one nation and one america
folks as i told every world leader i've
ever met with over
the years it's never ever ever been a
good bet to bet against america
and it still isn't we're the united
states of america
there's not a single thing nothing
nothing beyond our capacity
we can do whatever we set our mind to if
we do it together
so let's begin to get together
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you for your patience
there it is a speech by president joe
biden the first before a joint session
of the house and senate i can't remember
a more policy heavy
speech in such a setting from a
president in a very long time
it won't all happen it won't all happen
but an important framework
a lot of good ideas put forward and now
comes the hard work of actually trying
to get something done
but uh very very interesting speech
uh thick with policy there is bernie
sanders maxine waters
greeting joe biden
we are going to i promised i would do it
and i'm going to we are going to take
some calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord so don't go anywhere unless you
want to get away from the calls which
some people may want to do i understand
some people become irate uh
davidpakman.com
discord get yourself into the waiting
lobby
if you want to talk to me as joe biden
uh exits if you are heading out at least
make sure you're following us on twitch
we're at almost 82 thousand followers
there in fact just seven more
make sure you are subscribed on youtube
if you're leaving we're close to 1.4
million it's crazy what's going on
uh we see here joe biden
greeting any number of different people
um
let's hear from some people now let's
just jump right in as we observe what it
is that
uh that is going on uh why don't we go
to oh i don't know let's go to
let's go to manuel from texas you're on
the air
hello hello hi how are you
doing pretty well how about yourself
doing well
well um i i just obviously
finished up watching the uh joint
session like you did
and i think it's like obviously joe
biden is attempting to
try to bring congress uh pretty well
but i just still have a feeling that the
republicans are still not gonna care at
the end of the day
of course and i'm just worried about
like
like how would he actually try to do
this type of stuff
he's gonna have to do it without them
he's gonna have to do it without them
quite frankly and i think that what joe
biden did today
i don't know that it will convince any
republicans but it will make them look
more obstructionist when they don't
participate in any way
shape or form but i agree they're
they're these they barely clapped for
for ending cancer you know what i mean
it's like these are not people that are
going to work with him on anything
yeah and my also kind of like worry as
well is that like some of the senate
democrats as well it's like yeah they're
like you know obviously part of the
democratic party but they do
have some uh republican ideology
type of i mean more traditional
republican ideology type of stuff
but that as well might just hinder a
decent amount of stuff as well and i'm
pretty much worried about that just
overall in general yeah i mean listen
the concern now is how much of this
stuff can he get done i think that's
absolutely a fair question but let's see
let's now see for sure all right
all right thank you manuel from tejas
very much appreciate hearing from you
let's go next to zachary from tennessee
zachary what's on your mind
uh hey david um hi i was just rereading
griftopia
by matt taibi um and i don't know if you
caught the part where biden opened up
with saying that
um you know there are good people on
wall street but
i just wanted to know if you thought
that the tax increase on the ultra
wealthy was
feasible based on how they're able to
rig the tax code and basically write it
themselves it seems unlikely
yeah i think that i'm not familiar with
the book that you're mentioning but i
as far as the so i don't think the
capital gains increase is going to
happen
and the thing is even if it did people
will just
wait to sell uh on the basis that
um at some point the capital gains rate
will probably go down again
uh and there may be certain vehicles you
can
move money directly into in order to
avoid that you know i
i don't think it's going to happen and
you're right that if it did
there's going to be very few people
actually paying that higher rate um
40 on capital gains
yeah i just i also seem very wary just
because of the inability to get people
like mansion and cinema on board for any
type of meaningful tax increase
yeah i don't i don't think the cap gains
thing will happen i think going to 39
from 36 will probably happen
um yeah do you think we could see an
increase in the top uh marginal tax rate
back to what it was in the obama era
yeah that's what i just said 36 to 39.
okay yeah
thank you yup my pleasure uh i believe
this is richard neal
friend of the show who has been on the
program before i'm going just by
looking at the back of his head which
makes it a little difficult to know for
sure
but i think that that's who that is
let's go
next where are we going next there are
many
many people who want to get on here why
how about uh sam from alabama
sam you're on the air hi david uh thanks
for choosing me um pleasure i talked to
you
back in december i think after the uh
anyway so good i always get nervous but
i was just gonna ask you
um
i'm sorry i'm drawing a blank you'll
have to go to the next person
all right thank you very much uh very
much appreciate the call
from uh alabama very good let's go next
to brenda from minnesota you're on the
air
um well hello david how are you doing
today i'm doing well thank you
um yes
twice in a row i don't have anything
david are you busy brenda it sounds like
you're are you
making a puzzle or building a model
airplane or something there
that that's the fan at the back of my pc
so so i expect
uh the conservatives to really react to
i'm transgender i've called in before
i've talked to you before
um i think that they will um they're
gonna really focus on this
and and they're going to really get
pretty um
pretty offensive i mean it's a daily
thing for me on the internet but not not
in real life because i live in minnesota
we're saying here
but um you know
i i do appreciate um his mentioning
those things
and saying those things because it was a
very different world
um growing up it was a completely
different world for me
um and it and it's i can't even imagine
what it must be like
uh being being young and being trans
today right but
and i i apologize for the fan at the
back of my pci
my pleasure what do you maybe maybe look
into a heat sink or something like that
um i have nothing um
i didn't get a i didn't get it
[Music]
the thing from the government i'm i'm
all drawn
out of the bay i have nothing i i'm not
well off
i said no hold on what do you mean you
didn't get you did you qualified but
didn't get your stimulus yeah i didn't
get it i didn't get it
have you look have you tried to get it
because there's there's recourse you can
call in and get it
i have somebody i can talk to that can
help me i mean
they they they targeted so i had
problems
during the trump administration because
they
they wouldn't pay my bills at the
hospital
because i use my
legal name which is feminine but they
claimed that that was not real
and therefore during the trump
administration they claimed that
they refused to pay medicare any of my
any of my hospital bills
uh then that was just for just checkups
and things like that they wouldn't pay
for it
um so so i have
i'm sort of like not very not very
hopeful of bureaucracies and the
government i get listen i mean it's
this is a whole thing which we you know
exceeds our ability to look at each
piece but listen
if you haven't gotten the money and you
qualify for the money just google what
to do if you haven't received your
stimulus check there's a number to call
the ev
anybody can do this and you will get
your money i i would not
if you qualify just not get it you know
just call the number and get it i'm
skeptical because
you know i believe i'm sorry i i just am
i just
okay my history my history with the
government um
just isn't positive yeah i got you okay
um brenda call the number get the money
i think it's a good idea thank you so
much i i appreciate the call
uh yeah i know people who just like
they've posted on facebook 20 times i
never got the money
but they never called the number and
said i qualify and didn't get it and
everybody i know who has gets the money
very quickly
let's go to jesse from la jesse from la
you're on the air
jesse from la you're on the air hello
jesse you're on the air oh um
um i don't understand how um
uh how the parties are split okay
from um from far how can a uh
how can i how i can explain the sum
uh
tell religion i'm sorry and the
president
covered several topics including the
economy the coronavirus
sorry what um race in america
along with can you can you put me on
hold i'm sorry
okay you want to be off all right very
good uh that one did not go
it didn't go poorly it just didn't
really go anywhere
um let's see hold on who's someone on
the air right now i feel like someone's
i haven't put anyone on but somebody
seems to be on
hello
that's weird could have sworn i just
heard someone
let's go to william from texas let's try
that
william from texas you're on the air hey
hey david cameron yes i can
hey buddy uh good to talk to you a big
fan of the show thank you
uh really really quick um you know going
into this speech i i
uh characterized myself as a social
democrat yes
and i have i didn't have high
expectations but
to hear a president for the first time
say trickle-down economics has never
worked
yes it was actually relieving and i was
like oh my gosh uh a bernie bro gun
biden stan
well what's interesting is before this i
said
that you are going to see basically the
antithesis of reaganomics during the
speech i didn't expect
biden to actually say trickle down
economics has never worked
but then he actually said it and i was i
was thrilled i loved it
you know i and also something that um
i've been
worried about is that for me what i
thought covid was was essentially
the end of american hegemony you know
going into this
this era of you know uh china
essentially overtaking
every aspect whether it's g silk road
right or
you know just competing in the global
marketplace uh that
i i was essentially not optimistic but
honestly i know like you were saying
during the show
that hey probably not everything that he
talked about is going to get passed but
she has left me feeling optimistic
and i hope my fellow americans feel the
same way beautiful
and you don't think biden's going to war
with china do you
i i don't i don't um i i do think
in terms of a global trade war again
i think hopefully uh he has better
policy experts than
yeah i know that's that's not saying
much yeah
i i do think that um he should build a
global coalition whether it's
south korea japan you know singapore
uh taiwan so that we can actually
address the
the problem uh that is rising uh over
overseas so um i i think it would it's
absolutely absurd but
is it al the realm of possibility no um
beautiful
um so to rank your call uh
10 on audio quality absolutely pristine
audio quality
uh nine and a half on getting directly
into your question without asking how
i'm doing
very good um only a seven on accent you
know
if if you were scottish you would have
had a perfect score across the board but
you can't do much about that
i i have to say i have my own podcast
and you are one of the few people
uh that i can point to that have
inspired me to do my podcast so thank
you i appreciate it
uh but no seriously uh love i love
listening to you every day and i hope i
hope to jump back on the show eventually
let's do it all right we will flag you
as a good caller uh
uh and uh composite score 27 which is
very strong
very strong beautiful all right thank
you there it is
um it's gonna be hard to top that that
will be very difficult to surpass
but we'll try a little bit let's go to
isaac
from ohio you're on the end oh hello
david i apologize for the swearing how
are you doing today
we're doing well awesome i was just
following your coverage of the uh
of the joined session and i had
something to say and then something to
ask you i don't know if you um
if you happen to follow marjorie
taylorgreen on twitter um i do myself
just because of
you know the free entertainment but she
um it's
it's it's truly incredible to me david
um
how how great a display of cognitive
dissonance there is
between people who uh people who worship
those outside of the class interests and
um
she was just going going on a rant on
twitter
and i i know a lot of people who um who
who who eat all that up which kind of
leads me into into my question for you
yes um i i i kind of re-awakened
politically a year
ago and it was it was george floyd's um
killing was my radicalizing wrong
because i i kind of just
i watched how the right responded and
nothing
all the consistency that i was led to
believe for my family and those around
me who are older
just completely fell apart and i'm
wondering david if you think there
is a point in someone's life where
they abandon all once-held
principle and turn into a reactionary
because it
seems like there's it's very very
generation
generationally driven yeah
uh i am not so sure about that
but um there there's a lot there it's a
very meaty
topic and i would need to devote a
little more more thought to it but i
appreciate you for presenting it so
eloquently
oh my my pleasure dave david thank you
so so much for having me on all right
thank you
uh we are not covering the rebuttal guys
it's just
you know it's all socialists and we
can't afford anything there's just
i'd rather talk to you guys if you are
dead set on
listening to the uh rebuttal speech it's
certainly available elsewhere we'll look
at we'll have the video up on screen but
i'm just it's just it's just not a good
use of my time
um i want to uh to hear from you guys
why don't we go to dennis from newark
and you know i don't know i've never met
anyone who
lives in newark i know the airport i've
flown in and out of it dozens of times
but
you live in new york
hi david um no actually i don't live in
newark that's that's just
to keep me more anonymous oh okay well
so it you know
the reason i i would pick a different
place because
nobody i've ever met lives in new york
so it became a topic of conversation you
know
that that's great i'm familiar with
newark but i don't live there
okay but anyway um i uh i just wanted to
ask you
in terms of the uh the step in the right
direction
yeah um so my ideology
is social democracy is a start okay uh
defunding the police is the start uh
it's not gonna happen right um
but you know that's that's still
ideological it's
politically um maybe i'm a little more
flexible
but do you do you think that
ideally with climate change and all of
our problems
um biden would do his his job
in trying to mitigate the disasters
of these issues of these crises and
not only with the obstructionism of
mitch mcconnell
and the republican senate but also
um but also with joe manchin
how he's wielding an enormous an
enormous amount of power
is it going to be possible to get much
of this work done i believe it will i
think that it may come down to budget
reconciliation but i think that
by the way are you are you swatting
flies there no i'm not i'm i'm just
speaking
um with my headphones off oh okay all
right um i think that that it will take
budget reconciliation but i do believe
that joe biden is going to get at least
one or two of these big three things
done
i don't think republicans are coming
along with them um but i
i do think so okay there's not going to
be any defunding of the police i mean
biden doesn't support it
um and so and almost no democrats do so
that's definitely not going to happen
but they're not even going to try
th that's that's fair yeah thank you all
right very good
um and to clarify i'm not part of the
defund movement
i'm part of the reform movement and
people can check out my vid
many video clips about that let's go to
kim
from mcdonough where is it mcdonough
what state is that
kim
kim from mcdonough please unmute kim
last chance for kim from mcdonough
all right that's too bad
let's see who else we have today
um trying to go to someone we've not
maybe spoken to before
how about uh oh i don't know how about
sarah from milwaukee wisconsin
hello hi so
i had a lovely conversation with a bunch
of my friends
since we're all vaccinated and got to
actually like see each other in person
okay and while we were speaking
we had a really interesting
uh i suppose not even proposal
prediction
uh come up one of our friends suggested
that he doesn't see
republicans coming back into power or of
any
sort until 2032.
yeah i mean who the hell knows see the
thing is we can't even predict what will
happen
between now and 2022 that will impact
that midterm so it's just like what is
there to even argue about you know
who who the hell knows what's going to
happen in 2032
right right i mean there's part of me
that really would love that to happen
because i think there's more progress
that's going to be happening
if republicans are not getting their
strange
death cult claws on everything uh i mean
what i would say
is historically speaking it's
probably not true that republicans won't
take control of something
before 2032 that's typically the way
it's gone so
my main thing is i don't think we can
predict anything 10 years out
but if it's even odds i would probably
bet
republicans do take control of something
before
2032 because that's typically the way
it's gone in history
right right it's like maybe eight years
but then something else has got to give
yeah maybe 2022 i mean they could take
the house in 2022.
right right it could be something
absolutely crazy
yeah i also do have a kind of silly
question to ask
uh do you think mitch mcconnell is
really
just a lich
lich what does that mean i'm not
familiar with that term uh a lich is
actually
a character from dungeons and dragons
who is basically
an undead wizard okay
i am very much out of the entire um
tabletop type thing so i couldn't tell
you one thing or the other about it
i think he's he's very he's very
turtle-like but lich i couldn't say
okay thank you very much all right sarah
from milwaukee
pretty strong call actually i i don't i
don't dislike that call
let's go to u.s navy sailor donnie
from arkansas you're on the air hi david
how are you uh just a couple things um
so i noticed that joe biden didn't
mention student loan forgiveness in the
speech that's perhaps
that's because maybe that's uh not
necessarily something congress needs to
be instrumental in
i mean hopefully it's not because it's
not much of a priority
for his for for him but from what i've
been reading
the administration is looking into it
um i'd like to you know hear your
thoughts on that
and also just one of my observations
um you know we saw a lot of uh shots of
of lauren bobert or yeah whatever you
say her name is
vile woman um yeah by absolutely a
garbage
uh human being um and so
um we saw a lot of shots of her and
other republicans
not clapping and i just want to say
these people
they are feckless they are
and they're i mean i hate to say it but
they're really fed by
um delusional and ignorant voters that
make up their base
and unfortunately they're not going away
you know they're
absolutely forced to be reckoned with
and i don't really know what that means
for our country and governing going
forward but they really just
are insufferable they cannot be
convinced of anything that is
a critical of their uh dear leaders
and i just think we have to be honest
about this we
are clearly a divided country and it's
not you know
just over things like oh we're tax
breaks good or
spending okay like oh no it's a much
bigger divide
yeah it's it's about in most instances
basic knowledge right and wrong moral
immoral
you know sanity and insanity really yeah
nothing to add to that
on on student loans quite frankly i
think biden didn't mention it because
it's just not a big priority for him it
doesn't mean the things he's working on
are bad
i just i just don't think the student
loan thing is a big priority for biden
gotcha yeah listen donnie you've scored
really highly i would say
10 on audio quality uh 10 on jumping
right in
and probably nine on accent there's a
very
slight accent which i we like i think
yeah and um very very good phone call
yeah from i'm from arkansas so i'm sure
i'm sure there is thank you you don't
sound like bill clinton though that's
for sure
oh no no all right my uh really great
great uh great talking to you
all right thanks thanks very good um
so it now it's really tough to top that
i don't know how we could possibly
supersede um why don't we try
let's try uh let's try danny from
ireland are you up are you awake in
ireland still what is it 3 30 in the
morning there
i am indeed actually david thank you
very much for uh talking to me it's
really
really nice watching your show after the
last little while is this a normal time
that you stay up
uh probably shouldn't admit that
that is true yeah okay very good i'm a
night owl i kind of run on american time
for lack of a better term a lot my
friends tend to be
canadians and americans so well please
proceed you're scoring very highly in
the accent category
oh it was i was i was thinking this to
myself that i was like oh i have this
accent category in the bag
[Music]
no the um the thing that i wanted to
talk about was um
[Music]
very similar to the last question was
actually the the um
student loan forgiveness yeah like if if
the democrats were to go about
something like this in the kind in the
current
climate that they're doing and with
schumer talking about
legalizing marrow or bringing marijuana
down to a schedule 2 drug
sure do you think that that well
yeah kind of do you think that they're
going to be able to kind of try to use
that revenue that tax revenue
in order to at least boost those kind of
those kind of more
oh i don't know i mean i i like the idea
which is
you you regulate cannabis and then it
generates revenue and then all of a
sudden you found the money to do some
student loan forgiveness i just don't
think that that's
it's just not how these things operate
in practice these are political things
they're not
you're thinking of it like hey we found
some money here
and here's where we can spend it and it
just works perfectly but that is not how
these things actually are negotiated
and there's an ideological opposition to
paying off student loans for many people
yeah one i do understand to a degree
like it's it's one it's a super
complicated topic it's really
interesting to talk about though because
you do get that kind of
it's one of those issues where both
sides kind of have a point
and it's a nice change it's a nice
change it's like there's a little bit
you have a little bit on both sides
where you can kind of go oh well what's
the what's i mean i think
i think the valid point from people
against the student loan thing is
explain why we should pay off all
student loans for everyone like i'm not
there you know i think we need some
forgiveness
as a baseline and then we do more based
on particular situations but i've not
heard a good convincing argument why
it's just everybody gets
all their loans paid off that i'm not
there
yeah i would be very very similar to to
that viewpoint i just wouldn't i
wouldn't be there i don't have a reason
to be there because
like it's not it's not needed for
everybody at the same time is we have
like i thought i'm pulling stuff out of
thin air to be fair
but like it's the idea of you could go
about the idea of going through a means
test far and going like right
just making up figures right we get
everybody gets 10 grand of
student loan forgiveness and then means
test for more if you need it
right so like oh i really can't pay pay
this off okay
i've this this and this are all
accounting for the reasons why i can't
pay for it
i have good clear reasons for this i
need more help
perfect yes we'll help you out more but
it's like
gates it also doesn't deal with the cost
of college issue which is sort of like
how we even got into this mess in some
ways it's going to some degree it's
student loan forgiveness is kind of like
it's putting a
bandit on a bullet wound instead of
stitching it up like
listen question for you uh what is the
highest tax rate in ireland the income
tax rate
oh uh the highest tax rate in ireland
is under forty percent i think earlier
um no it's uh oh sorry over 150
000 euro a year it gets to 60 something
percent
really wow yeah so the strong rate wow
yeah it's the way we do tax in ireland i
don't know how it is in different
countries i actually
never really looked it up yeah um i'm
only 23 so i'm barely figuring this
stuff out for myself
beautiful but um so here for example
you're not taxed on any income
underneath 20 000 euro okay
between 20 and 35 000 you're taxed i
think i think it's 15
or 20 or something like that and then
there's those tax brackets where we'll
go up and tax you
within that tax bracket if you know what
i mean so yes your whole income doesn't
get taxed on you it's a marginal rate
yeah yeah yeah yeah
just like in the us yeah perfect okay
interesting 60. we'll look into that
uh and then when we had we've had a
couple callers from scotland explained
that
sodas are referred to sometimes as
coke gingers or as fizzy drinks
uh what do you guys what do you refer to
the category soda
in which there is 7up fanta coke pepsi
etc what is the category of drinks
called
oh um
i've never thought about that um
[Music]
usually genuinely that's such a weird
on-the-spot question i'm so sorry um
so let's see if we can maybe back it up
uh does the term
is the term soda the one you would use
no right no
and is it is it pop
you see old see my grandmother would say
pop my grandmother was 92 and she passed
like 10 years ago okay so like
all people oh a lot well a lot of older
people would say
pop but yeah now it's just it's just
it's just fizzy drinks fizzy drinks okay
that's fine
it's just like it's just it's just a
drink yep
that's interesting um and are are you
guys big on soda stream
in uh in in ireland where you you
carbonate your own
seltzer at home no but i had
one of my friends show me that when i
was about 13 and he
blew my goddamn mind really
this technology even existed and it was
like
danny you can make your own carbonated
stuff i was like what
and i spent about three hours figuring
out how or and just like that sent me
down a rival really really interesting
but no it's
very unpopular here it's something you
could probably you could probably give
most people a what is that a real thing
technology moment well i mean but people
you know it's being carbonated somewhere
you just
the the shocking part is it happening at
home i guess you're saying it happening
at home yeah it's like that's
that's far too that's far too much for
us that's witchcraft yeah
like that's that this is compelling it's
like we'll go we go from
we understand computers uh we understand
everything about loads of stuff about
computers and loads of stuff about the
soil
yeah everything in between we haven't
soil you understand soil in ireland
yeah we're farmers through and through
man oh okay
yeah like we'll sell mysticism like
we're great for this kind of stuff
especially with americans in general
like it's the whole thing of
because so many of our people just left
yes that's just what we do is we will
just leave
ireland it's like ireland's great
because they'll set you up
they'll teach you whatever you want to
know and then they'll send you somewhere
else to make money
huh is there is there any uh kind of a
unique or niche potato that maybe most
people haven't heard of that that you
have tried that you like
golden roosters are pretty fun is that
like is that different than a yukon gold
i will tell you right now one second
golden rooster that is
that is interesting yukon uh
yukon gold potatoes there we go
a variety of second generation seed are
you going to be
free-skinned yellow tingy flesh yeah
they would be kind of similar
oh okay from what i'm largely tasty but
yeah so
um they look basically the same but okay
you know the way that like these would
be kind of a waxier potato inside they
wouldn't be as fluffy
wow yeah arrows would be a bit waxier
are you a doctor of potato
uh basically so for outside of ireland
yes
inside of ireland not at all okay like
there's other people who know a lot more
than you about it
mm-hmm yeah this is great if i go out
into the world i could pass as a potato
doctor
horseradish and mashed or yes or no on
that
oh no no okay all right i'm gonna have
to let you go okay
is that the cleanser is that the that's
that's just too much for me yeah we
can't that's not
that's too much yeah no but i i really
do appreciate the phone call
uh you too david thank you so much for
very good it was really nice to speak to
you thank you golden rooster
that is that is something else all right
everybody listen i appreciate everybody
who joined me we
really can't do any better than that so
we're gonna we're going to end on that
um we will be back with so many
different things tomorrow you know
follow subscribe
like report my accounts uh all of those
different things
and we'll see everybody very soon
you